Welcome back everyone happy comic con week this
is going to be my new star wars ahsoka trailer
video we finally have some actual footage to
look at this is going to be for the regular
ahsoka episodes that are airing next year
it's the mandalorian spin-off series even
though it'll probably feature flashbacks to
the clone wars hayden christensen said that
he's going to be in the series most of it
is meant to take place in the present day
after the events of the mandalorian season 3 or
around the same time as the mandalorian season 3.
i will be doing episode videos for the series
just like i do for the mandalorians so be sure
to subscribe to get everything it is going to be
awesome as of me posting this video it is comic
con week so there's going to be a ton of trailers
posting i'll do as many videos as possible too the
black panther 2 trailer is probably going
to be one of the biggest things this week
but there'll be a bunch of other marvel trailers
there's also going to be a new star wars and or
trailer soon too because that series is starting
i'll be doing episode videos for that but i'll
talk more about that when they release new
trailers for it the brand new ahsoka footage
starts with ahsoka walking to the bridge of what
seems like the ghost by herself it could be the
ghost it could be another ship there's no one in
the cockpit she's wearing the same brown robes
that she was wearing at the end of the book of
boba fett when she was with mando luke skywalker
and grogu on the planet that luke skywalker's
new jedi academy is on which they've since
actually canonized is ausas which is actually a
big deep cut for the legends canon osis used to
be the capital of the ancient jedi order they had
some easter eggs for that during the mandalorian
season too when they included the tython easter
egg that's like another ancient jedi planet
we're talking like the jedi that predate the old
republic like very very old ancient jedi but in
all this trailer footage it seems like her clothes
haven't really changed that much since the end of
the book of boba fett or the mandalorian season
two like she's still wearing the same basic outfit
they did make a big change to her leku is her
tails coming from her head on the mandalorian
season two in the book of boba fett they gave
her shorter leku just because they said it was
easier to film with her practically like there was
some issue that they had doing a really accurate
version to the animated ahsoka that you've seen
the past several years but when they started
filming the ahsoka series they did a big retune
on the way that they just visualized the ahsoka
character practically the way that rosario dawson
looks when she's walking around in all the makeup
and the costume so now her leku are way longer and
she looks a lot more like the animated version of
ahsoka from star wars and clone wars and star
wars rebels so if you're a big stickler about
stuff like that you'll probably be happy with the
changes that they made for the ahsoka character
then as she presses a button they switch to the
soundtrack and it's a very different type of
soundtrack than the mandalorian series it sounds
more like the music was inspired by a samurai film
which was kind of the vibe when they debuted her
character during the mandalorian season 2 episode
7 samurai yojimbo throne of blood even inspired
the original star wars a new hope movie so dave
filoni really went to star wars roots when
he borrowed imagery for the tone of the
samurai films for ahsoka it sounds like all the
ahsoka episodes will just be more in the tone
of that episode the only major difference with
that ahsoka episode is that most of it took place
at night and they're not gonna do like the entire
ahsoka series at night case in point all this new
ahsoka trailer footage from her series is during
the day so as she pushes the button near the
cockpit they transition to the soundtrack into
the title sequence playing that samurai sounding
music and they transition to a different episode
of her outside in what looks like the ruins of an
ancient jedi temple around a bunch of columns that
look like they've been destroyed for a long time
it could be the ruins of some old republic planet
from before the rise of the empire but the fact
that it's a really ancient looking temple with
the columns the designs on the floor that she
searches through just makes it sound like it
has more connections with the old jedi order
from before order 66. as she walks through the
ruined columns of the temple they transition to
a cena for walking into a room on a bigger ship
or a base with what looks like a republic officer
some droids and the big thing obviously is right
next to her is live-action harris syndulla i've
talked about this before long-running theory they
did cast mary elizabeth winstead is one of the
main characters like a really big character going
forward but they wouldn't say who she was playing
she was also at star wars celebration this past
year just a little while ago with ewan mcgregor
she is his real life partner like they just had a
kid together and they made a lot of references to
the two of them like the couple of them together
both playing really big star wars characters in it
being kind of funny if their child did not grow
up being a star wars fan so it just sounds like
she's meant to be this really big character
which is why i think it's going to be hera
there's another scene on the interior of the
same ship just in a different place it could be
the live-action ghost it could be another ship it
just seems way bigger than the animated version of
the ghost ship from star wars rebels but i think
part of the idea is that most of the footage they
showed off of the team together is the live-action
crew of the ghost on the actual live-action
version of the ghost there's a different scene
of a human female hand reaching out through the
force at a drink like they're using the force
trying to grab the drink and it seems like it's
the same ship and it might be sabine wren because
of the color of her skin it just seems like the
hand belongs to the actress that's playing her
natasha bordizzo they even brought chopper on
stage so they're gonna have live-action chopper
on the ahsoka series but as far as i could tell
chopper didn't show up in any of the trailer
footage they showed off but the next trailer
they do have will probably feature some of the
other characters that were in the first one
really hoping that they put grand admiral thrawn
in one of those trailers too obviously they're not
going to put him in the first teaser trailer but
you know that he's going to be part of the ahsoka
series in some way don't worry i'll talk about
thrawn in a second too and if it wasn't clear
this person who's grabbing for the drink with
the force ahsoka's hand would be a way darker
shade of orange and she doesn't use the force
in such a casual way like that and if it wasn't
clear sabine wren is force sensitive a lot of her
storyline during star wars rebels especially the
later seasons was about the dark saber itself
which obviously they're dealing with in the
mandalorian season 3 right now remember the whole
arc of the dark saber with sabine was that she won
it in combat defeating gar saxon in their bid to
place boca tan as leader of the mandalorians but
that was before the events of the original trilogy
and a new hope before the great purge sabine gives
the darksaber to boca tan which is supposed to
be this new age for their people obviously things
went a little bit sideways but that's where the
armor told mando that things went wrong for their
people and for bogotan because she didn't win the
darksaber in combat kind of put a curse on their
people like there's this whole hanging cloud curse
that it seems like they're trying to put on the
mandalorians during the mandalorian series they'll
get into that really heavily because a big part of
the plot is them actually going to the planet
mandalore again the wreckage of the great purge
there's this whole thing going on in the
mandalorian season 3 with bogatan the mandalorian
and the armor all three of them deciding on what
the fate of the mandalorians are going to be all
mandalorians in each one having their own agenda
with mando kind of stuck in the middle trying to
decide where his allegiance lies do you want to
support bogotan or do you want to regain your
honor and do what the armorer is telling you
to do and join your old cover to mandalorians
my early theory is that he's going to pull an
ahsoka because obviously we're talking about the
soka character the ahsoka trailer he's going to
go his own way like ahsoka did she left the jedi
order but she didn't go to the other side like
she didn't turn into a dark jedi she didn't join
the separatists she just forged her own jedi path
separate from the jedi order which is why ahsoka
isn't a jedi in present-day technically she's
not a jedi even though she's highly trained and
very powerful in the force like she could train
grogu in the force even though earlier during
mandalorian season two she made a big deal about
not doing that but then there's a new scene in the
trailer of ahsoka inspecting old jedi designs on
the floor probably in the same areas that ruined
temple we saw her in earlier and then they show
a brand new scene of an architect droid on that
same ship that they keep going back to and it's
the exact same model of droid that david tennant
played when he was in the clone wars episodes on
the jedi ship during that series they explained
that the architect droid was basically just there
on the jedi ship to help new jedi create their
lightsabers but he wasn't the only architect droid
he was just a model of architect droids so i don't
know if this is going to be the same droid as we
saw during the clone wars over to be a completely
different one there's a scene of sabine looking
at the mural from the end of star wars rebels like
it's the exact same scene from the end of star
wars rebels but done in live action with a
live-action version of sabine in the live-action
version of ahsoka with her touching ezra bridger's
face obviously letting you know that they're going
to pick up where they left off with the story and
tell what happened after that but also find ezra
bridger during the course of the series i know
there's all kinds of theories about who they cast
as that character you can post your theories below
there's more footage of ahsoka at the ruins
of that jedi temple unfurling her hood they
show the title sequence and the music like i said
reminds you a lot of a samurai film so obviously a
big plot of the series is going to be her trying
to find out what happened to ezra bridger that's
what sabine is trying to do and also she is mostly
looking for grand admiral thrawn that's what she
was yelling about at the end of the mandalorian
season 2 episode 5 where is grand admiral thrawn
the whole idea is that in present day thrawn has
made it back from the unknown regions and they
actually just showed some star destroyers during
the mandalorian season 3 trailer and the big thing
about star destroyers is that there are very few
imperial capital ships left over from the remnants
of the empire after the destruction of the second
death star the empire kind of had its last stand
at jakku they call it the battle of jakku it was
there that the remnants of the imperial fleet like
all the capital ships that were left over all
the star destroyers all the really big ships
were mostly commandeered and then taken into
the unknown regions where they basically
morphed into the first order that was right after
return of the jedi so obviously this is like a
couple years after that that's why in present
day the mandalorian there are no capital ships
or there are very few capital ships otherwise
maf gideon wouldn't be using a cruiser he'd
be using a full star destroyers his main ship so
the whole idea is that when you start seeing star
destroyers showing up in the mandalorian season
3 it probably has something to do with thrawn
because thrawn commands a fleet of star destroyers
that he came back from the unknown regions with
but the way they're playing his character is
that he's going to be the big bad of this era of
the timeline like they're doing a version of the
thrawn trilogy like heir to the empire trilogy but
in the mandalorian spin-off series they're sort
of doing the marvel avengers thing where you have
a bunch of different series interconnected and
then they all cross over in a big team-up type of
project and that'll be them versus grand admiral
thrawn so we might get a tease for his character
at the end of the mandalorian season three like
this is who it is even if we don't see the actor
on screen and then we'll probably see him for
real like his actual face during the ahsoka series
post all your theories in the comments below who
will they cast as live action thrawn still kind of
think it's going to be large mikkelsen because
he did the voice of the animated character and
that's kind of their thing like he is a very
notable live-action actor so he could actually
do a pretty decent job as the live-action version
of thrawn lots of new comic con trailers posting
this week make sure you enable alerts for my
channel so you don't miss anything everyone click
here for my brand new mandalorian season 3 trailer
video in easter eggs and click here for my black
panther 2 dr doom video thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe and this is the way!